-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
We're hanging out with BTS!
Their new album
"Map of the Soul: 7" is out now.
They're gonna do
a giant performance
at Grand Central
later in the show.
Right now, I want to challenge
you guys
to a little friendly
competition.
It's time for
"The Subway Olympics."
-Let's get it.
♪♪
-Round one -- protect the duck.
Each player must balance
a rubber duck
on the back of their hand.
Try to knock off
the other player's duck
without losing control
of your own.
Jimmy versus Jimin.
-Go!
-Hey, my son.
[ BTS oohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-I got that one, right?
-Hey!
-Jimmy wins.
Jungkook versus SUGA.
-Go!
[ BTS oohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, SUGA!
-Wow! Wow!
[ Rubber duck squeaking ]
-Jungkook wins.
J-Hope versus Jin.
-Go!
-Get him!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Jin wins.
RM versus V.
-Go!
♪ -La, la, la, la, la ♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-V wins.
Round two -- dance your shades
and gloves off.
The first player to fling off
their shades and gloves
by furiously dancing
wins the round.
Jimmy versus Jungkook.
-Whoo!
-Go, go, go!
♪♪
[ BTS ohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Come on! Come on!
-Winner!
-Jungkook wins.
Jin versus V.
-One, two, three.
-Let's go.
♪♪
[ BTS oohs ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Jin wins.
Final round --
post-it challenge.
Get as many post-its on your
body as you can in 15 seconds.
Jin versus Jungkook.
♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-Who won? Who won? Who won?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
-20, let's get it.
-21.
-Not 21.
-I'm not touching that one.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15,
16, 17, 18, 19, 20...24.
-The winner!
-Jungkook wins!
-Stick around, everybody.
When we come back,
we're gonna get
some authentic New York deli.
Come on back.
♪♪
-Hi, Jimmy.
My New York story is one day
I'm walking down the street.
Actually, no, I'm standing still
on the street.
And this lady walks by me.
Without stopping she goes,
"You're famous."
And another guy,
who does not know her,
walks in the opposite direction,
looks me up and down and goes,
"No, you're not."
Neither of them stop walking.
Happy New York.